so
i'm here to talk about 3d and one thing
i really
i'm really convinced about is that in
the next couple of years
we will see a lot of 3d games i mean
aaa games running on the broader right
now
with the initiative of for instance
mozilla with smgs and some stuff
we're also doing with ie we are pushing
the limit of the web
and without plug-in just by using a
webgl
we'll be able to have really great games
that's why with some friends of mine we
decided to create something
to help web developers creating games
without having to deal with
math shaders webgl plumbing which is a
bit annoying
we wanted to have something really
really simple i mean
we wanted to have something that can
allow you guys
to create a game and just focus on the
game
and not the plumbing we create for that
babylon gs
and for the next 20 minutes i will try
to shrink my time
we will talk i will show you how to use
it my name is david kechu i'm working
for microsoft
and i will do three crazy things
i will use windows i will use
ie and i will use visual studio
so yeah it will be just
different here is my
handle at delta feel free to contact me
on twitter my mail is there and my blog
is here
so first of all i would like to show you
how to use babylon js
so let's move here
try to
sounds good okay so just
i just need visual studio to have some
kind of local
web web server okay so the only thing i
need
is to create a website
it's not related to visual studio i'm
joking you can use whatever you want
just as long as you have a web server so
let's just
use a blank website here and
i will just drop in babylon gs
tweet
oh that's interesting you can't see it
okay let's duplicate it should be great
better
yeah sounds good guys
okay so i will just had
a web page let's find a web page right
there
and i will call it index.html
in this webpage i just had here babylon
gs the only thing you need
is a canvas who
is we already played with webgl here
okay let's say five percent okay
absolutely i can
is it powerful yeah it's visual studio
did i mention that so let's call it
canvas and what i want to do here just
add some
css quickly just to be sure that my
canvas
will use all the screen so html
body and canvas
will be full screen
and 100 with same thing 8
sorry about that it's just 12 something
really beautiful to see you to show you
okay
sounds good and what i want to do
here let's close that
is add a script and in this script
i will just create an engine an engine
is for you
the best tool to not deal with webgl the
engine will do everything
related for to webgl for you so you just
have to create
a new babylon dot engine object right
there
give it the canvas
let me grab it
yep and name of the canvas is canvas
okay and
use it here when you create the engine
the second thing you have to do is
create a scene the scene is the
container or everything you want to
display on your screen so it's like in
in movies let's create a new babylon dot
scene
and the scene only need to know who is
the engine
once the scene is created you can create
a camera so the camera is you is your
point of view
where are you in the scene there is a
lot of camera
there are a lot of different cameras in
babylon gs i will use a
um rotate camera the archotec camera is
a camera
that will rotate around the central
pivot okay so it's really convenient to
for instance
look into some specific object it's new
babylon dot
arc rotate rotate camera
let's give it a name like camera
two value this is the different angle
there is two angles to position an
object on a sphere
called that alpha and beta so let's say
zero the reduce of the speed of the seer
let's say 10
and the center which is the center of
the pivot
it will be here babylon.vector3.0
and finally the scene once the camera is
created
we can ask the camera to get all the
control
on your canvas i mean all the input
touch
mouse whatever will be handled for you
by the camera if you want to just
to do some gesture to pinch zoom
whatever the camera will take care of
that for you and will move accordingly
so the camera just have to call a chat
attach control
on the canvas then we need a light
so let's create something like a small
sun
which is a babylon dot point light
the point light should have a name light
we also have a position it's just a
point that's a dot
and we are in 3d so we need the vector3
it's xyz let's put it
in let's say far from us
somewhere there and always the scene
so we have the camera we have the light
the missing stuff is an object
let's create a sphere
it's babylon dot mesh
that creates sphere so sphere has a name
it has a definition remember that you
are working with 3d so everything is
based
around triangle even a sphere so if you
want to create a sphere we have to
define the tessellation which means
oh mini triangle what's the definition
was the resolution of our sphere so
let's
base on 32 the radius of the sphere will
be let's say
three and the scene
and that's it the scene is complete what
we need right now is to ask the scene to
render
as fast as possible okay and on modern
browser we have something called request
animation frame
which handle that for you each time the
browser wants to display a frame
it will call you you will do what you
want to do and then the browser will
display your frame
on browser that doesn't support that you
can use seti mod for instance so
just to be convenient here we can ask
just the
engine to run the render loop which is
the
technical term with a anonymous function
and during
this function the only thing we want to
do is just call render on the scene
and i think i'm done if there is no bug
oh it's a sphere
the bad idea is that i have a rotate
camera on a spherical object so you
won't see when i move you just just see
the light moving a bit
but i when i move with my mouse and i
rotate around my sphere
what i can do right now is just add some
texture
let's play with that quickly i will add
this one and this one
because right now the sphere is a bit
let's say simple
the material is for you the convenient
the convenient way to not deal with
shaders
i will go back to that after but right
now i just have to
declare a new babylon
dot standard standard
material this material will have a name
and a
scene and
the sphere will use it
as a material okay the material will
allow you to
create shaders without having to code
the shaders for instance i want to use a
diffuse texture
the diffuse texture is the texture that
will be used for the basic color of the
object
according to the light okay so right now
the object is white
when the light is on it it's white where
there is no light is black
okay and right now i want to have an
object a bit more complex so i want to
use texture
to define the color of the object when
the light
light lit it so it's a new babylon
dot texture the texture is
html5.png which is in my project
and the scene is just to see
far better we have something interesting
the light is at a specific position
and the light is not moving i'm just
rotating my camera around the object
what i can do quickly is just use my
render loop here to say that light dot
position
is equal to camera good position
position so the light will be
on my head like this so when i move
the light will move with me interesting
what can i decide also and i have
plenty of options right there but i can
decide that the diffuse texture right
there which is a png
and so the texture contain
alpha i can define that
alpha is enabled so the shaders
will understand that when there is an
alpha value
equal to zero the pixel must not be
drawn
okay just by adding this line
the object right now is not a complete
sphere
and as you can see babylon gs is
removing the back face
just to be sure that we don't display
too much faces but in this case
we need to display the best the back
face so
i just ask the material back face
curling to disable that
fault and then i can see
inside my object i can go further
and i can add something name the bump if
you're a gamer
the bump texture or normal map is
something really used
it's a technical way to simulate a
volume
without having to deal with triangle in
fact the object is
only a two triangle really simple but
with a texture
applied on it we can simulate the
modification of the light we call that
the bump
it's a bit complex if you want to
develop that
but with dublin gs you just have to say
that the bum texture
same way is a new texture
that we can use here and this time the
name is normal
normal map dot jpeg
and as you can see we can feel the
volume
nothing different on the geometry side
this is the same object oops
i can play with the touch obviously
and as you can see we feel the volume
because the light
is not perfectly applied on the surface
of the object
there is some scratches and we can feel
the volume
all right
back to the slides
i shouldn't have that's not a good idea
right
if you are like me i hate learning new
things using documentations
i know that a lot of people spend a lot
of time writing documentation
but i hate that i really hate that i
prefer experimenting i prefer
learning and trying my new toys on some
kind of sandbox or things like that
as a developer i think i have to switch
again to duplicate
sorry about that yeah as a developer i
created for you
the tools called the playground
let's go with it you can experiment it
right now it's on babylon gs dot
slash playground is a place where you
can try
specific babylon gs features without
without having to deal with
creating an html index.html
sounds like i could use my
local version
as you can see here oh that's great okay
grant
there is no problem with that let's go
to the playground
you should have the same thing online
almost oh my network is just
broke down yeah i know
trying to make it work i'm sorry guys
what a wonderful demonstration
no
i'm connected
just for your pleasure
no okay so let's imagine
the background look like this stuff it's
a place where you can
on the left side you have some kind of
editor where you code editor where you
can type in and select
whatever you want to do and you can just
try it immediately because the right
side of the
application is just a live example of
what you just
code and i would have loved to
make it work
oh thanks good okay so
yeah this is the best of my
demonstration
so here you have a playground layer you
can see and just on the left side you
see that you can create a camera attach
control cut light
just what i did and just try things each
time you want to learn
new thing we have some kind of tutorial
right there for instance let's play with
shadows
okay so as you can see loading a set
okay it's okay so you just have this
kind of environment
it's an eight map it's a plane they form
using a texture and there is a donut
flying with two shadows which is the
interesting part and not the flying
donuts
and all the code is here it's less than
30 lines of code
we really try hard to
be sure that each time you want to do
something it's with the minimal
amount of code you can go
in some kind of advanced mode if you
want you can deal with shadow you can
deal with everything related to webgl
but for the beginner of the
or the people that don't don't want to
mess with that you just have to
stick with the first level api here you
can see i create two lights each light
have some specific stuff around shadow
which is there
called the shadow generators and the
shadow generator will
do everything for you it will generate
the map apply it on the object
it'll do everything for you all right
you can also create i'm sorry about this
presentation it's easy because each time
you change the resolution you can also
deal with shaders it's the interesting
part
shaders can allow you to go really
deep into high quality visual i mean you
can create
things like that with a new tool called
cyos which means create your own shader
okay it's this time you will have
specific
object sphere torus or my preferred duck
knot
and you just have here the vertex shader
and the pixel shadow
and using this small amount of code
which will be
executed on the gpu side it's glsl it's
a specific language
it looks like c you can explain to the
gpu
how each pixel are rendered
and if you want to play with that there
is some sample here the basic one
it's just reading a texture then you can
go
a bit complex and adding some kind of
black and white
and adding cell shading like in video
game
and fong which is the name of the guy
that find
o the light equation is defined and blah
blah blah blah blah and you can play
with some kind of funny things like the
wave
everything sorry everything is just glsl
is just shader code and if you want to
do that guys
you can experiment using cyos
and then you can use it on your own code
and i prepare for you a specific
sample right there
so same same story i just referenced
babylon gs
and there i create a script with the
type
which is not javascript just to be sure
that the browser don't want to compile
it
it's the code that i copy past from
there
the first one here and the second one
the vertex and the pixel shaders
i put them here and then i do the same
thing i create a canvas an engine has
seen a light tutorial with the cam and
the material i use right there
is a shadow material meaning you take
the control over all
the pixel is defined you have to create
the shadows put that code into your page
and just choose this object
so if i run this page
my donut here i apply on it some kind of
cartoon
red effect just by creating the shadow
material right there we try to keep
things simple you just have to mess with
webgl you just define all the shadows
and all the stuff all the plumbing is
done
then
you can see here it's some kind of
developer demonstration i mean it's a
sphere donut okay if you want to create
a game
unless you have some great idea with
donut and sphere it will be
limited let's say you will have to work
with graphics
or 3d artists and to do that they don't
use sublime text visual studio whatever
they will use their own dcc they will
use their own
data creation tools and
one of them is blender it's a free
open source project extremely powerful
where you can create
really beautiful scene we decided to
support blender
and to do that it's pretty easy let me
just create something
the best i can do is create a monkey
head
it's easy for the record this monkey
name is susan i don't know why and
as you can see there is a camera right
there so it's perfect and there is two
objects
i will just add a plane here i
will zoom it to be sure it's a ground
for me
okay and what we did we
added some specific functionality into
blender to allow you to control
up specific properties
and when you want you just want to
export babylon gs
file right there and you
just have to load it into your page so
let me
just select something here
not really
okay it's okay here you can see some
specific babylon gs features for
instance
for my ground i want my ground to
check collision meaning i don't want the
camera to go
through this object i want the camera to
consider it as a solid object okay
then for my camera right there i also
want
to have collision and gravity
and the gravity is like in on earth it's
down
going down then on the monkey head i
will add
something different i will have physics
i want the head to use the physic engine
and be considered as a box for instance
with a mass of one
and for the cube i will do the same
thing i will
consider it as a box with a mass of one
and
the ground i will consider it as a box
but
i don't want the ground to fall down i
want the ground to remain
where is it to remain static so i just
define a mass of zero
it's a bit strange doing that i just
have to export everything
on my desktop for instance
and blender will generate for me
that babylon file you can load that
using
this kind of code
and by the way i will show you also the
sandbox
during the same time
trying to load things so the sandbox is
just a place for designers to just drag
and drop
into the browser the generated file just
to be sure
that they are look okay they can try
and simulate all the object will appear
when it will be rendered using babylon
gs
yeah that's it okay
you just drag and drop thing here and
you can see that they are physic
and i can move with my camera
and if i go out of the world oh i'm just
falling down
yeah it's strange
to load this kind of file it's just one
line of code same thing you just have to
call
scene loader oh please scene loader dot
load and it will load for you the file
and everything will be accessible
a new scene is created for you a new
camera a new object everything
as i shown you prefer just before but
with just one line of code because it's
coming from blender
we also spend a lot of time working on
different in future input you can we
handle the touch
the pointer event stuff even on chrome
and firefox because we are using
end.js which is a polyfill for pointer
events
we also use a device orientation so you
can move your tablet or whatever and
just uh
control your camera virtual joystick
with two fingers on touch mode like in
uh
on the phone for instance an ugly camera
if you want to have a
3d effect with red and green and oculus
with just one line of code you can plug
an oculus on babylon gs
and have your head movement that can
control the camera
something i will just show you quickly
and i will go to this one
because we support this is the microsoft
moment because we support
html5 and javascript as native language
you can just create a new project which
is named
in reversal up drag and drop inside
everything
like babylon gs the code that you
sorry the code that you want to use here
oh i have the code to load something
here
babylon sceneloader.importmesh will load
the skull.babylon file which is just
there and if i execute that
on my emulator right there it will be a
new native app
here it's a skull
it's not mine not yet
and using touch you can i don't know if
it's a good game but you
can play with the skull perhaps i can
win some money with that i just have to
publish that on the application store of
windows phone i can do the same thing
with windows 8. nothing else
just put your javascript code and it
works
and finally but not the last
as you probably noticed i'm french
and ubisoft also and
we decided to work with them to prove
that
a big brand i mean ubisoft can
create games on the web obviously there
is a lot of problem we have to
deal with like iep protection and
things like that it's another part of
the problem but right now the
feasibility
the things that studio game studio can
create a game and
push it on the web we did that with
assassin's creed pirate
so if you want to try it it's babylon gs
running with the assets
of assassin's creed pirate the game is
pretty simple it's
a race you have to go through
all the the way point
like this you can change the weather if
you want to go something more
front here it's the end of the of the
world
yeah it's better it's florida
i do all the race in
one minute and 10 seconds just to let
you know
do what you want and for you developers
we also launched a contest and you can
win
xbox one obviously with assassin's creed
pirate black chess edition
this is the only way to win that
specific edition i don't know
what they're inside i'm sure there is a
lot of cool stuff
you just have to go there so let me show
you
if i can
so create your own shader slash acpf for
assassin's creed paragraph
race it's the same shadow editor but you
can
play with the pirate ship the assassin's
creed pirate ship
and you can try to create a specific
shutter for that ship
okay not not yet uh and if your shutter
is the best one you will win the
xbox one and the black chess edition
okay so i go quickly on that
ah crap i click on the full screen
button
everything is free everything is on
github it's not a microsoft
related project i really like to insist
on that it's my project it's a personal
project
i spend all my night my wife rather
recognize me right now
on that i it's
open source you can contribute it's pure
javascript no
we moved to typescript two weeks ago
it's pure
typescript right now but you can
contribute if you want using javascript
everything that you may want to have in
a 3d engine should be there if not just
let me know and i will add it
so it's a commitment
some specific and useful link
thank you
you